nous sommes le vendredi 5 décembre
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
Journal de la rédaction aujourd'hui des
citoyens déçus de l'action de la gauche
interpelle les responsables locaux et
nationaux c'est à La Verrière une
réunion publique vient de se tenir sous
l'impulsion du maire communiste Alain
Haage en présence de nombreux élus entre
entre 14 et 18 millions de Français sont
bénévoles en cette Journée mondiale du
bénévola Estelle Carasso reutman la
directrice départementale de la cohésion
sociale et notre invité et puis comme
chaque fin de semaine l'essentiel de
l'actualité depuis lundi journée
mondiale de lutte contre le sida retour
de Nicolas Sarkozi et sur un plan plus
local la course cycliste parinis qui
démontre une fois de plus son
attachement aux
zivelin 20 ans de prison requis hier
jeudi à l'encontre de quatre jeunes
originaires des Mureaux jugés en appel
pour le meurtre d'un homme de 30 ans
sous les yeux de sa famille après un
accrochage entre véhicules sur la 13 le
procès se déroule devant la Cour
d'Assise d'appel des hautes scènes le
verdict devrait arriver dans les
prochaines heures et l'on verra si la
justice décide de suivre la demande de
l'avocat général qui a dénoncer donc
hier une loi de la cité qui se nourrit
uniquement de force et de violence
verdict à suivre donc dans la journée
hier soir une réunion citoyenne qui
s'est tenue à la verrière en compagnie
d'élus locaux et nationaux des partis de
gauche une réun pend laqu les ver ont pu
présenter leurs cintes mais aussi leurs
attentes ml
William la salle du scarabé était
presque pleine ce jeudi soir une
centaine de verriers rois et habitants
des communes voisines avaient fait le
déplacement avec des motivations
différentes moi c'est pour parler des du
cœur du manque de d'approvisionnement et
l'ugmentation des bénéficies je viens
ici pour
m'informer avantage sur ce que la gauche
peut faire pour essayer de remédier la
situation actuelle essayer de faire
pencher la balance plus à gauche voilà
il y a il y a un petit peu un désespoir
je pense que ce désespoir si on le
laisse ça va ça va amener à la
catastrophe le désespoir le
désengagement des citoyens la mairie le
ressent lors des derniers scrutins une
motivation pour organiser cette première
rencontre il fallait réagir réagir face
au désengagement des citoyens qui semble
assez écœuré pour le moins de ce qui se
passe au niveau national et réagir parce
qu'on peut pas se résigner à ce que ce
soit comme seul issue soit le retour de
Nicolas Sarkozi soit l'abstention soit
le Front national prenant tour à tour la
parole les verriers rois ont ainsi
soulevé des problèmes des
questionnements autour de l'emploi du
logement de la crise des interventions
préparées lors d'un précédent atelier en
phase de des élus locaux mais aussi des
représentants des partis de gauche et
des élus nationaux je crois que c'est
très nécessaire dans la situation où
nous sommes parce que c'est une
situation difficile à
expliquer beaucoup de gens parmi tous
ceux qui critiquent la politique
actuelle n'apportent pas pour autant des
des des propositions des suggestions
positives donc il est essentiel de
pouvoir entendre ce que les citoyens ont
envie de de dire à leurs élus la commune
espère que ce type de rencontre
deviendra
la
croissance politique toujours l'UMP et
l'UDI réunis ont donc dévoilé la semaine
dernière les noms des candidats au
prochaines élections départementales de
mars des cantons sont néanmoins toujours
10 réservés on ne connaîtra qu'en
janvier ceux qui aspirent à siéger au
conseil général c'est le cas à
Rambouillet où Christine Boutin sortante
n'a pas pris de décision sur son avenir
et puis à Montini Guy encour
actuellement détenu par le maire
socialiste de Guy encours François de
Ligier si ce dernier a déjà lui annoncé
qu'il bréguerait un nouveau mandat en
face pas encore de nom en dem 2007 c'est
Michel logier le maire de Montini le
Bretonneux devenu depuis président de la
Communauté d'Agglomération qui s'était
présenté face à
lui aujourd'hui nous avons des personnes
qui
réfléchissent et qui demandent le temps
de la réflexion et c'est tout à fait
respectable parce que ça démontre bien
que aussi bien à Rambouillet qu'à
Montini nous n'avons pas des gens qui
sont dans le moi je moi je moi je je
vais être candidat je vais être candidat
je vais être candidat mais quel est
l'intérêt quel est l'intérêt général
quel qu'est-ce qui va permettre en
l'espèce à laakquie de profiter d'une
dynamique commune avec le département et
nous en sommes à ce moment de réflexion
et ça mérite qu'on prenne un peu de
temps donc nous aurons le plaisir au
début de l'année prochaine de dire ce
qu'il en est laissons cette réflexion
cheminer en profondeur c'est très très
important cette association entre la
future communauté d'agglomération
élargie qui aura donc plus de poids plus
de pouvoir plus de puissance et un
département qui reste quand même le
fédérateur de ces intercommunalités donc
comment articule-t-on les choses voilà
c'est encore une fois ce sont pas des
réflexions d'ambition personnelle ce
sont des réflexions d'intérêt général et
si ça doit prendre un peu de temps
laissons je crois que c'était monsieur
mitéron qui disait qu'il fallait laisser
du temps au temps pour cette séquence je
veux bien être mitérandiste
François Pierre Bédier qui soutient
François mitéran c'est assez surprenant
inedit j'en perd l'ordre de mes mots
dans cette phrase c'est aujourd'hui
vendredi en tout cas que débute une
nouvelle édition du Téléton un événement
toujours porté par ses bénévoles cela
tombe plutôt bien puisque aujourd'hui
c'est aussi la journée mondiale du
bénévola bonjour Etel Carasso Rutman et
bienvenue sur ce plateau directrice
départementale de la cohésion sociale
nous allons faire le point sur
l'engagement des citoyens dans quelques
instants auparavant un micro trottoir
vous êtes-vous déjà engagé en tant que
bénévole c'est notre question du jour
vos réponses au micro d'elod moine et de
William l les restos du cas je pense que
c'est important quand on voit les gens
pauvres actuellement quoi donc du coup
je je vois qu'il y a beaucoup de
chômeurs beaucoup de chômage et tout ça
et c'est très important de d'y
participer association de parents
d'élèves reste du cœur on en manque dans
le sens où la société devient très
matérialiste et centrée sur elle-même
voilà chacun se protège ouais dans un
dans un refuge c'est c'est super j'y
suis encore mais j'y vais de temps en
temps je peux oui il y a très longtemps
je trouve c'est sympa parce quand soit
on n pas tellement de problèmes c'est
bien de pouvoir venir en en aide aux
autres passeport av venir pour aider des
jeunes issus de quartier dit défavorisé
qui av pas forcément les moyens de
d'avoir les liens avec le milieu du
travail d'être préparé à rentrer dans
les grandes écoles le bénévolat qui se
porte bien si l'on en croit ce micro
trottoir ils sont nombreux les bénévoles
dans les ivelines tout domaine confondu
he oui alors ils sont nombreux on en
dénombre à peu près 15000 donc c'est
quand même une bonne crue on arrive au
9e rang au niveau niveau de tous les
départements français et excusez-moi
15000 c'est le nombre d'associations
c'est 180000 bénévol 10 FO plus 180000
et et donc classé parmi les meilleurs
départements en tout cas en France
Téléton restons du cœur UNICEF
CroixRouge et Maus quels sont les
associations qui attire le plus sont ces
associations là plutôt porté vers le
social parce que c'est très large le
bénévolat voilà alors le social c'est
vraiment ce qu'on connaît peut-être le
plus puisque il y a énormément de
campagnes médiatiques et on va bien le
voir aujourd'hui avec le télét
mais quand on dénombre le nombre
d'associations dans les différents
secteurs ce qui arrive en premier c'est
le secteur des loisirs et notamment du
sport où là on a environ 60 % de
bénévoles dans les Yvelines puis
viennent les associations
militante
environnement voisinage enfin on peut
trouver différentes associations de ce
type et enfin le domaine social
curieusement qui est le dernier mais
avec 23 % de bénévoles donc les domaines
le domaine sport sportif les loisirs
c'est important parce qu'il faut ces
bénévoles pour s'occuper des jeunes des
moins jeunes les parts de
responsabilités que prennent ces
bénévoles sont toujours de de plus en
plus importantes vous êtes là aussi pour
les aider les conseillers parce que on
fait pas n'importe quoi qu on une
association fait tout à fait il y a
beaucoup de bénévoles qui ont besoin
presque de professionnalisation parce
que c'est vrai qu'on s'engage on a envie
de faire quelque chose et puis la
complexité administrative par exemple ou
la complexité financière fait qu'on a
besoin de de soutien donc nous notre
rôle c'est de organiser par exemple des
sessions de formation en lien avec une
association ivelinoise qui s'appelle
Profession Sport et vie associative pour
soutenir les les bénévoles on a
également des comités sportifs qui
mettent en place des formations euh et
on a une organisation départementale on
a ce qu'on appelle un point euh
yvelinois de la vie associative qui lui
est
constitué à la fois d'élus et
d'associatifs pour faire remonter les
besoins du terrain et d'ailleurs le TER
terrain sur lequel nous sommes la
casquie est très en pointe dans ce
domaine et si vous avez besoin de
conseils n'hésitez pas donc à contacter
vos services pour pour en savoir plus
quel est le portrait il y a les
coordonnées qui vont s'afficher bien sûr
à l'écran quel est le portrait robot du
du bénévole on peut en faire un bah on
peut en faire un on a tendance à dire
que c'est un homme de plus de 60 ans à
la retraite alors ça c'est vrai dans les
instances dirigeantes mais c'est vrai
aussi qu'on trouve de plus en plus de
femmes et de jeunes mais là peut-être
plus dans des
domaines plus ponctuels par exemple ils
viennent au resto du cœur ils viennent
dans à la Croix-Rouge mais ils sont
peut-être moins inscrits dans les
instances dirigeantes où là c'est quand
même l'homme plus âgé qui gouverne ou
parce que le bénévola ça peut faire peur
parce qu'on se dit je n'ai pas beaucoup
de temps j'aimerais bien aider mais 1
heure par-ci par là 2h quelque fois on
franchit pas le pas et pourtant c'est
important ça peut aider des associations
une heure ou deux de donner de son temps
de donner c'est important il y a des
bourses d'ailleurs au bénévoles la
France qui est l'un peut-être des pays
de l'Europe où il y a le plus de
bénévoles et de volontaires la part de
ceux qui donnent leur temps pour les
autres est passé de 36 % à 40 % entre
2010 et 2013 c'est une étude du réseau
recherch et solidarité comment on peut
expliquer cet engouement pour le
bénévolat de plus en plus c'est parce
qu'on est en temps de crise et c'est la
solidarité qui prime mais je crois que
chez les jeunes il y a une volonté
d'engagement nous on le voit très bien
par exemple au niveau du service Civic
volontaire euh alors certes ce n'est pas
du bénévolat complètement puisqu'ils
reçoivent une petite indemnité mais
c'est quand même la marque de l'envie de
faire quelque chose pour leurs
concitoyens et on a une augmentation de
plus en plus notable du nombre de jeunes
en service CIVI et on a aussi beaucoup
de jeunes qui s'engagent dans des
associations comme les resto du cœur la
Croix Rouge c'est c'est évident le
travail du bénévole est suffisamment
reconnu est-ce qu'il y a encore du
chemin à faire de ce côté-là je pense au
Passeport bénévola par exemple ça ça
permet de valoriser l'expérience est-ce
que ça marche bien peut-être rappeler ce
que c'est il y a un tas d'actions si
vous voulez qui permettent de valoriser
le bénévolat alors le passeport bénévola
c'est un document qui permet d'inscrire
toutes les actions qui ont été réalisées
par une personne c'est très intéressant
pour les jeunes aussi euh parce que
c'est quelque chose qui est bien pris en
compte par des recruteurs donc au moment
de s'engager dans la vie active le fait
d'avoir de montrer qu'on a fait du
bénévola c'est quelque chose de très
important et d'ailleurs le ministère de
la jeunesse et de la vie associative
avait il y a 2 ans passer des
conventions avec différentes sociétés
grandes sociétés hein pour justement
permettre cette valorisation donc c'est
très important c'est bien vu par les
entreprises aujourd'hui parce que
quelque fois les entreprises peut-être
même auparavant avaient peur en se
disant ou là c'est une personne qui va
s'engager beaucoup pour les associations
qui sera peut-être moins productive du
coup dans l'entreprise dans ce temps-là
est révolue oui parce que je crois que
ça montre aussi un désir d'engagement et
que une société qui recrute elle a
besoin de gens qui s'engagent on va
parler à présent du du Festival du film
de la cohésion sociale pour conclure cet
entretien ce sera le 8 décembre ce lundi
au cinéma le Roxan à Versailles c'est un
peu tôt C à 9h mais on vous y donne bien
évidemment rendez-vous vous vous allez
l'organiser il y aura trois films
projetés oui alors il y a trois films
qui ont évidemment trait à des
problématiques de cohésion sociale dont
on s'occupe mais qui en plus sont portés
par des associations c'est-à-dire que on
verra dans ces films comment la vie
associative permet à des citoyens bah de
mieux vivre leur leur parcours notamment
on a un film sur les personnes
handicapées qui s'pp et pas que
handicapé des personnes qui risquent la
discrimination qui s'appelleent n'ayez
pas peur on a également un film qui
s'appelle Joséphine et la beauté où on
va parler d'un atelier qui permet à des
femmes qui souhaitent travailler de se
remettre un peu à
flot notamment au niveau de l'image de
soi et puis on a un film là qui est un
film commercial en avant-première mais
là c'est le Roxane qui le passe ce n'est
pas la direction de la cohésion sociale
mais qui sera toujours autour de cette
thématique he bien évidemment de
l'engagement c'est ça 5 € c'est ouvert à
tous donc vous y êtes les les bienvenus
une dernière question est-ce que le le
bénévolat le dynamisme du B bénévolat ça
veut dire qu'il faut aussi s'inquiéter
sur l'état de la société parce que les
choses vont mal il y a plus de bénévolat
parce que l'État se désengage on a en
plus besoin des bénévoles mise beaucoup
sur la solidarité honnêtement je pense
que ça marche ensemble c'estàd que
personne ne peut faire tout seul ni
l'État ni les collectivités locales et
c'est vrai que la vie associative bah
permet à la fois de prendre en charge
trop se reposer non plus sur les Béné
les associations absolument c'est pour
ça que nous on est là aussi pour pour
les soutenir et pas uniquement se
reposer sur ell merci etê venu donc sur
ce plateau en ce vendredi merci à vous
et puisque nous parlons des bénévoles
c'est donc aujourd'hui vendredi que
s'ouvre le Téléton des milliers de
bénévoles sur le terrain pour une
trentaine d'heures d'animation afin de
récolter des fonds pour lutter entre
autres contre les maladies génétiques
rares juste avant le coup d'envoi de ce
marathon nous avons rencontré
quelquesunes des personnes qui
s'engagent c'est à manie les mot le
reportage de yolen
Torz dernier préparatif avant le jourg
dans les locaux de l'association
Objectif Téléton manikois on se prépare
pour le grand rendez-vous de l'année
et là on met le vélo oui rouge et ce
sera un gros lot
d'accord à l'occasion du Téléton
l'association va tenter de récolter un
maximum de dons au profit de
l'Association française contre
l'mopathie Patricia 67 ans à la retraite
est engagé ici depuis 5 ans c'est venu
comme ça avec le temps avec les
relations en fait on a des amis qui qui
sont dans des associations qui ont
besoin qui demandent de l'aide une fois
deux fois trois fois on voit ce que
c'est et puis et puis on rentre dans
l'association avec la vingtaine de
bénévoles devenu pour certains des amis
elle prépare les 30hur de l'événement
depuis le mois d'octobre ça permet de de
rester en contact avec des gens
actuellement je suis à la retraite et
sans ça je m'ennuieraai chez moi
l'avantage c'est justement de d'avoir
l'impression d'être encore utile à
quelque chose faire appel aux
associations aux commerçants et
entreprises de la ville pour récolter
des dons préparer les décors la loterie
ou ou encore la restauration autant de
missions qui demandent du temps et plus
de bénévoles on en manque c'est vrai que
ça repose beaucoup sur les mêmes
personnes bon je comprends très bien que
les gens qui travaillent c'est pas
évidentin même si on fait des soirées
des soirées bénévoles et des soirées
travail bon on arrive à avoir des jeunes
mais on manque de bénévoles c'est sûr
c'est sûr qu'il en faudrait plus plus de
1000 Laus ont été récolté pour cette
édition 2014 l'année dernière la ville
de manie avait récolté 27000 € environ
20000 € sur place et 7000 € en promesse
de don sur internet ils espèrent faire
encore mieux cette
année seconde partie de ce journal et
comme chaque vendredi l'essentiel de la
semaine à présent avec tout d'abord
lundi une nouvelle mobilisation contre
le sida 1er décembre Journée annuelle de
lutte pour les associations qui rappelle
notamment que deux jeunes sont touchés
chaque jour par la maladie et que parmi
parmi les étudiants français ils ne sont
plus que 33 % à utiliser
systématiquement un préservatif écoutez
la réaction de jérô André président de
l'association HF prévention l'avion
contacté par téléphone il y a une
flambée de de la contamination donc sur
2013 plus de 7 % en plus de cas de
personnes céropositif ça n'était pas
arrivé depuis 10 ans donc effectivement
on se rend bien compte aujourd'hui en
France que que l'épidémie est en train
de repartir et donc plus que jamais la
ministre appelle à plus de prévention et
plus de dép puisqu'on sait effectivement
que le dépissage et la prévention sont
vraiment les deux piliers de la santé
publique aujourd'hui puisque vous parlez
de de chiffres aussi celui-ci équivalit
dans le sens de ce que vous nous
expliquiez deux étudiants sur 3 67 % qui
n'utilisent pas systématiquement de
préservatif pour un rapport sexuel et
même un étudiant sur 3 qui ne l'utilise
jamais c'est une enquête qui a été menée
par une mutuelle étudiante Laas sm REP
là on est dans le cœur de votre mission
c'est la prévention il va falloir
retourner encore plus sur le terrain et
expliquer les dangers tout simplement
alors effectivement nous notre cœur de
métier c'est la prévention et le
dépistage on a sorti donc en juin
dernier et ça a été lancé donc mardi
dernier sur TF1 la grande campagne de
communication pour promotionner
l'application Cup qui justement permet
de trouver donc et de se le géolocaliser
pour trouver des préservatifs mais aussi
donc des lieu de dépistage parce
qu'aujourd'hui on se rend bien compte
qu'il est plus que nécessaire de pouvoir
connaître son statut sérologique les
chiffres sont d'environ 30000 personnes
qui s'ignorent n on pense que c'est
beaucoup plus en réalité effectivement
sur les milieux ouverts ciblé
c'est-à-dire les universités les centres
commerciaux en 2014 on n pas encore
vraiment les chiffres définitifs mais on
serait à plus de 2 % c'està dire quand
même 08 de plus que l'année dernière et
on se rend bien compte que chez les
jeunes et et la SM a complètement raison
il fa enfin le présque est complètement
abandonné dans l'actualité aussi cette
semaine la victoire de Nicolas Sarkozi à
la tête de l'UMP une victoire avec près
de 65 % des suffrages qui suffisent à
rassurer ses partisans sur le plateau en
début de semaine l'un d'entre eux
responsable de génération Sarkozi dans
les Yvelines il est entré en politique
en 2007 avec la présidentielle et la
victoire aux élections donc de l'ancien
chef de l'État génération Sarkozi dont
je suis responsable pour les evlines là
aussi c'est une force énorme qui a
soutenu Nicolas Sarkozi parce que c'est
avec Nicolas Sarkozi que beaucoup de
jeunes se sont engagés en politique ça a
été la locomotive et on a envie de
continuer avec cette locomotive qui est
Nicolas Sarkozi il est le renouveau avec
l'équipe don dont il s'entoure et il a
envie aussi d'apporter des idées neuves
le fait qu'il a été chef de l'État je ne
vois pas en quoi ça l'empêche d'apporter
des idées neuves de renouveler le parti
et de renouveler la façon dont il fait
la politique ce qu'il a envie de faire
vous aviez quel âge lorsqu'il était
Président euh vous disiez nous amener en
politique oui donc moi j'avais j'étais
au début de mes 20 ans j'étais j'avais
la vingtaine ouais et vous n'étiez pas
engagé en politique avant Nicolas
Sarkozi non non non non moi je j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser justement en
2007 quand je venais juste de passer mon
bac et Nicolas Sarkozi bah ça a été le
premier à me à me donner envie de
m'investir vraiment dans un parti et
c'est là que j'ai pris ma carte je
trouve que ça serait trop dommage de
gâcher euh l'exercice démocratique qui a
eu lieu ce weekend il faut faire la
transparence sur les sur les fonds du
parti sur la situation financière il
faut également redonner l'implication
des militants dans la vie du parti ceux
qui a envie de faire Nicolas Sarkozy il
y a une deuxième chose c'est redonner
une ligne politique claire aussi à l'UMP
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec le Centre
voilà on a eu cet épisode malheureux
avec Alain Jupé mais ça montre aussi
quelque chose ça montre une attente des
militants UMP qui veulent qu'on qu'on
qu'on soit fier de nos valeurs avec une
ligne politique claire la troisième
chose donc dont moi je voudrais parler
en tant que responsable
c'est deonder la struct des jees UM
parceaujourd'hui on n pas de on n pas de
de gouvernance claire dans cette
structure là c'est très important parce
que ça représente beaucoup de monde
beaucoup de militants on a besoin de
formation et puis la 4rième chose c'est
de moderniser le parti il faut comme le
disait Nicolas Sarkozi intégrer la
société civile dans le parti il faut
aussi refaire l'équipe dirigeante voilà
faut dire les choses aussi faut pas se
cacher se débarrasser de l'armée
mexicaine dont on a hérité après la
guerre copéfillon voilà on a multitude
de secrétair nationaux je pense que
c'est plus efficace d'avoir une équipe
plus resserrée et vous que pensez-vous
du retour aux affaires dans son parti au
moins de l'ancien chef de l'État micro
trottoir ah bah c'est un combattant
c'est plutôt bien moi je trouve
finalement hein il c'est pas plus mal
que les autres bah m'a un peu surpris
quand même ben parce que quand même il a
pas mal de casseroles comme on dit euh
ça m'étonne que qu'on lui fasse encore
confiance dans son propre camp ben je
pense que c'est une bonne chose pour
l'UMP cont tenu de la situation pendant
laquelle on a été
pendant 20 et quelques mois depuis
décembre
2012 la dernière tentative d'élection
c'est une catastrophe donc j'espère que
qu'il va réussir tout ce que je peux
dire bah c'était prévisible les Français
sont couillons donc ils continuent à
leur lancer je sais pas les Français
veulent pas du renouveau donc voilà on
s'enfonce encore un coup il faut des
jeunes enfin franchement la France elle
vieill à VI d'œil et personne s'en
aperçoit c'est une catastrophe si c'est
si moi je trouve que c'est grave ouais
voilà pour vos réactions sur ce sujet
politique les Yvelines premier
département équestre de France il était
donc logique que nous y fassions une
escale à ce salon du cheval qui se tient
à Paris jusqu'à dimanche vous propose de
revoir ce reportage que nous avons
consacré mardi à l'éthologie les
explications de yolen Torz et d'éod
moine c'est une première au salon du
cheval l'éthologie prend ses quartiers
et bénéficie d'un pôle entièrement dédié
au cœur de cette nouveauté le hara de la
sens très connu dans les ivelines il
organise des démonstrations et des
témoignages de professionnels tournerz
aussi de l'autre côté que mon cheval
respecte une limite entre moi et lui
est-ce que je vais
pouvoir développer une complicité et
pratiquer une équitation plus
respectueuse de l'animal c'est tout l'en
jeu de l'éthologie défini comme l'étude
scientifique du comportement du cheval
cette approche se développe depuis
plusieurs années en France bien
comprendre l'animal savoir communiquer
avec lui va aider le cavalier à avoir
des meilleures compétences d'éducateur
de chevaux par exemple ou améliorer ses
performances en en équitation ou en
sport ou passer des meilleurs moments
parce que les réactions qu'il va avoir
vont être compris par le cavalier et
donc bien bien appréhendé et donc une
meilleure relation avec lui permettra
une meilleure pratique équestre cette
étude du comportement des chevaux a même
été intégré dans le passage des galots
et des examens fédéraux l'un des
premiers secrets c'est de commencer à
travailler à pied à côté de l'animal des
fois quand on est dessus ben on a déjà
un petit peu peur de l'animal donc à
pied on va comprendre avoir les premiers
cont contact et commencer aussi à
éduquer le cheval à pied et en tant que
piéton quand on est nouveau cavalier
c'est déjà rassurant parce qu'on a pas
le problème d'équilibre et puis ensuite
on va se retrouver sur son dos avec plus
de confiance et cette confiance là va
permettre justement d'améliorer la
relation avec le CH l'exercice de sauter
l'exercice de dresser devient simple et
ensuite on préparera plus tard la
performance d'une d'un exercice physique
entra
plus lors du salon qui réunit tous les
passionnés d'équitation certains
saisissent l'opportunité de s'essayer à
cette pratique expérience très
sympathique et envie d'aller plus loin
pouvoir faire la même chose avec bah
d'autres chevaux moi je ne suis pas
propriétaire je suis juste cavalière
mais j'ai envie d'évoluer vers cette
équitation une autre approche
deéquitation travailler avec un cheval
qui a envie et pas le
contra le salon du cheval se tient
jusqu'à dimanche au Parc des Expositions
de ville peinte tous les jours des
démonstration d'éthologies vous sont
proposé et si à l'équitation vous
préférez la petite reine vous serez sans
doute ravi d'apprendre que le parinis a
décidé de renforcer son implantation
dans les ivelines pas moins de deux
rendez-vous programmés pour le coup
d'envoi de la compétition au mois de
mars Anthony
reche entre parinice et les Yvelines
l'histoire d'amour ne s'arrête plus les
8 et 9 mars prochain la Course au Soleil
s'élancera pour la 6e fois du
département laav Chevreuse c'est
indissociable de la mémoire et de la
légende de jacqu antil les grandes
années du Grand Prix des nations donc du
Grand Prix des nations dans les années
jusqu'au championnat du monde sur piste
en février prochain et à parince l'année
prochaine comme ces 5 dernières années
et comme encore au moins deux autres
autres années ça veut bien dire quelque
chose puis il y a surtout dans les
yelines ce lien évident réel concret
entre la pratique de la bicyclette au
quotidien et le cyclisme des Champions
avec l'ouverture du Vélodrome national
de 50 ans en Yveline et ses 70000
hectares de forêt le département des
ivelines est désormais une terre propice
à toutes les pratiques du vélo il y a un
peu plus d'éditions en dehors des
ivelines que dans les Yvelines mais
c'est vrai que ces six dernières
éditions ont vu s'associé un département
qui est un département très cycliste
puisque à la fois de cycl tourisme mais
aussi de cyclisme de compétition avec
maintenant le vélodrome de c-qu1 yvelin
contrairement à 2014 un prologue de 6 km
700 lancera la course à travers la ville
de morpa les coureurs devraient partir
du parc du Bout d'é clos en passant par
la rue de la Tour pour terminer du côté
du boulevard Michel miseray c'est une
fierté puis je pense que je ne pouvais
pas espérer mieux en tout cas en début
de mandat d'accueillir cette 73e édition
du paréice ce prologue euh parce que
voilà ça va démarrer le dimanche 8 mars
pour ce qui concerne la course mais pour
ce qui concerne l'animation dans la
ville ça va commencer déjà dès le samedi
donc on va en profiter vraiment pour
faire rayonner la ville de morpaonour à
tous au lendemain du prologue la
première étape partira de saint-réil
Chevreuse pour une destination encore
inconnue mais le peleton devrait se
diriger vers le Loir etcher pour le
reste du tracé il faudra attendre le 3
février et la présentation officielle de
cette 73e
édition c'est la fin de ce journal
prochain point sur l'actualité en direct
lundi 18h il sera notamment question de
ce référendum à coignère dimanche les
habitants vont devoir se prononcer sur
l'avenir de la ville dans le cadre de
son intercommunalité on va voir des
images de coignère car le maire l'a dit
et répété il ne veut pas de nouvelles
frontières à son secteur de la
Communauté de Communes des étanss alors
que l'État pourrait lui imposer de se
rapprocher par exemple de 50 ans en
Yveline il a décidé de donner la parole
à ses administrés dans quelques instants
le 78 weekend pour vos loisir des
prochains jours tout de suite le
générique de fin de cette
émission